let's welcome in our other friend of the
conversation mike florio joining us from
pro football talk and mike here we are
chatting about these quarterback battles
they've been headlining most of the
pre-season here trey lance jimmy
garoppolo in san francisco cam newton
mack jones in new england how do you see
all of this unfolding
oh it really is amazing consider five
rookies were taken in the first 15 picks
we know the first two guys trevor
lawrence and zach wilson will start week
one with trey lance of the 49ers and
justin fields of the bears it feels like
it's inevitable at some point they're
going to get playing time and an
opportunity to take over i want to go
back to the conversation about cam
newton and mac jones is an important
factor here and bill belichick has come
a long way in a short period of time he
was saying not long ago cam newton is
the starter until someone else plays
better now tonight he said he's
undecided on who the starter is for week
one the key factor here cam newton
knocked out five days for a coveted
misunderstanding it's clear he's not
vaccinated and you can't count on him
every given day he's got to be tested
every game day he's going to be tested
he can be knocked out for any game just
like that week four buccaneers in town
you got a game plan ready for cam newton
oh he tested positive he's gone you got
to pivot to mack jones that's going to
be a huge factor in belichick's final
decision the guy that he knows he can
count on being available every game in
mack jones versus the guy who has to be
tested every single day because he's not
vaccinated in cam newton that is a very
real dynamic in how this covet situation
2021 can affect decision making very
interesting point there all right well
sticking with the quarterback saturday
trade rumors they started to pick up
surrounding deshaun watson it seemed
like a deal might get done mike and then
it kind of quieted down all day today
how do you see this watson situation
panning out with houston right now
well you know the bottom line catherine
is the texans have to make a decision on
her about tuesday what they're going to
do with deshaun watson are they going to
pay him to not play are they going to
find a way to stash him on injured
reserve what are they going to do he's
due to make over 10 and a half million
dollars this year if they're content to
pay him that amount and try to trade him
in the off season when there's great
greater certainty about his off-field
issues fine if they're willing to do it
if they're not willing to do it they're
going to have to do the best deal they
can one source told me today it's
basically a game of chicken will the
texans relent in their demands and do a
deal by tuesday or thereabouts i know
that watson and his camp would very much
like to see a trade happen the question
is will the texans reduce their trade
demands and will someone else kind of
meet them in the middle to make it
happen it's something to keep an eye on
over the next few days all right we're
also keeping an eye on the next few days
of that reduced roster deadline on
tuesday who are you particularly keeping
an eye on that could potentially be cut
well you know one name that just keeps
bubbling up that i think we need to pay
close attention to even though i don't
think he'll be cut he could be traded
jalen smith the linebacker the cowboys
he's got 7.2 million in fully guaranteed
salary for this year the cowboys are not
going to cut him no matter where he
lands on the final depth chart they will
keep him if they could move him via
trade that's a different issue
altogether because then you move that
salary and that cap space off the roster
that's a name to watch for a trade not
for a cut all right mike always good to
check in with you thank you so much and
a reminder you can hear mike florio and
chris sims and an array of other
contributors every morning on pro
football talk live that is weekday
starting at 7 a.m eastern right here on
peacock
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports